we're waiting for the decision of the
close the sky
it's necessary to stop
bombing our city bombing out the
civilians
bombing and killed
our people
if
the world needs
i don't say
time
i would like to say
days
give to us enough
weapons
enough possibilities to continue our
fightings it looks like there's
ukraine and russia and neither is
prepared to compromise in any way is
there any compromise how said my
president
ukraine
ready to talk
ready to discuss everything
but
we can't compromise
for our freedom
we can't compromise to our territorial
integrity
and sovereignty
so would you be prepared to give up
donbass
look
i say an answer to your questions
we don't
discuss
our freedom our independence
our territorial integrity
our sovereignty
all another issue
we can see things and disgust
and my presidents
my presidents are ready to sitting
in any days
in any place
of course it's necessary be
first place
but you're not prepared to give up any
territory
yes
no territory yes
so are you prepared to give up nato
membership
what were discussed we're not in the
nato
we see
the position of the nato
we're very upset
after the statements
of the last statements of the nato we
are here
it's impossible
we was shocked
really was shocked
they not say we are sitting and
discussed we are continue thinking over
where continued consultation
they give green lights to bombing
ukraine
if something happens to the president
is that the end of it
we are strong and brave people we do
everything that nothing happens with our
presidents because our presidents today
it's inspiration for all the world
he showed to all the world
that it's possible to not afraid
this is a problem because a lot of
countries
afraid russia
this is the basic problem of everything
our presidents show that he is here he
has continued to work he has continued
to fight things
nothing happens with our presidents
believe in it the rest of the
governments who are
supporting ukraine say they don't want
to make it worse
by actively taking part in
some military activity or even lending
jets
now
it's necessary it's like
if you have
uh call it
it's very good that i give to you
aspirin
but you need the vaccine
you understand you need much more than
what you're getting of course of course
and
what is very important
we're not afghanistan
each dollars
each small piece of the help
give to us opportunity to win
if we win
win all democratic world
if you will lost
it will be lost of everybody
we're crying about it all eight years
but now
it's a critical moment